did Terry Garr really boldly go off the
set to protest Star Trek's sexist
wardrobe choices that's groovy a Star
Trek the Original Series is the 1960s
sci-fi television series hasn't always
aged well in the years since its
original run blatant sexism both on and
off the screen was unfortunately par for
the course at the time something that
won Star Trek Alum notably called out
appearing in just one episode actor
Terry gar had an experience so
uncomfortable that she may have walked
off the set guard plays Robert to
Lincoln in the episode as Simon's Earth
secretary to Gary 7 whose mission is to
stop Humanity from destroying itself the
stakes are undoubtedly high but you
wouldn't know it considering the
Wardrobe though that the showrunner Gene
Roddenberry gave gar for the episode God
was already wearing a criminally short
skirt but Roddenberry insisted that it
be shortened by another two inches
according to the impossibleness happens
the life and work of Gene Roddenberry
author Lance parking recounted that the
actor was so insulted that she walked
offset but someone who was there at the
time has a different story in a
conversation captured an inside Star
Trek the real story assistant director
Robert Jasmine mercosi incident Terry
understood the machinations of show
business so she didn't object when just
before her first scene on stage Gene
went to work on her costume again Terry
looked embarrassed when she was called
to set for her first shot whether or not
she stormed off gar's negative
experience with Star Trek was a turning
point although she finished her work on
the episode she washed her hands of
anything to do with the franchise in the
future even years later in an interview
with starlock gar slammed the Star Trek
universe and its fans and even maligned
sci-fi as a genre we're really something
Star Trek fans believe that
and so do I sariga's sexist experience
at the hands of Gene Roddenberry speaks
to the troubled Legacy of the show and
its creator while elements of the
original entry in the Star Trek Canon
have been praised for being Progressive
the series and its writers have also
been criticized for portraying female
characters through a misogynistic lens
there are plenty of examples in season
2's a changeling a robot analyzes the
brain of Uhura only to label her as
effective and nonsensical because she's
a woman in the season 3 episode turn
about Intruder Captain Kirk is possessed
by his ex-girlfriend only for the team
to realize this fact due to how
emotionally volatile he acts
we were charged with Mutiny Beyond other
people involved with various chapters of
the Star Trek franchise over the years
have commented on its controversial
history and Roddenberry himself actor K
Mulgrew who starred as Captain Catherine
Janeway in Star Trek Voyager were mad in
a 2019 interview with the radio times
that despite rod and Barry's Visionary
status he and his original creation were
still stuck with outdated values it was
extremely misogynistic that's what it
was for years and the Next Generation
followed that to a certain extent modern
Berry himself was that way we are simply
going to have to change the sensibility
this ideology and we are but it's like
moving Granite it takes a long time
mulgrew's Voyager despite being the
first series led by a female Captain
also took a few giant steps backwards
after the first few seasons when Jerry
Ryan landed the role as a de-assimilated
borg seven of nine she had more to
handle than just onset tension with Kate
Mulgrew her famous corset on the show
was a source of discomfort especially
when she needed time to herself the
costume was so elaborate that she needed
help anytime she needed the bathroom
while camera code during a 2020 Voyager
reunion if I had to go it was on the
radio Jerry's going 10-1 that's 20
because you know I had to have somebody
dress me and then dress me it was a 20
minute thing to get me undressed go to
the bathroom get dressed go back to set
it was a thing lion became so
self-conscious that she even tried
limiting food and liquid just so she
wouldn't hold it production the actor's
skin tight suit represented an
objectification that Star Trek had been
moving away from and was a big reason
why Ryan and moguru notorious C didn't
see eye to eye thankfully in her
appearance in Star Trek Picard wines him
to have a much more comfortable outfit